pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez vous
et activer la petite cloche salue les
épis curieuse et les épis curieux
aujourd'hui nous allons faire des pop
corn
on va s'éclater et aussi
[Musique]
un peu d'huile
d'ailleurs maïs comme en anglais le
préfixe heures pop correspondant quant à
lui au bruit que génère la cuisson
comment passe-t-on de ce grain
parfaitement lisse et régulier à cette
forme chaotique et boursouflé et bien
lors de la montée en température l'eau
contenue dont le grain de maïs se
transforme en vapeur
la pression à l'intérieur du grain
augmente la vapeur cherche à s'échapper
elle pousse sur la coque du grain qui
finit par céder c'est drôle j'ai
l'impression de déchets une éruption
volcanique
une première fissure se dessine et le
maïs éclater la vapeur peut enfin se
détendre et la lie donc contenues dans
le grain de maïs prend du volume comme
un ballon de baudruche et voilà du pop
corn
deux chercheurs français ont étudié de
très près le phénomène en 2015 et ont
apporté leur grain de sel dans cette
histoire ils ont découvert trois choses
d'abord ils ont remarqué que l'explosion
du maïs se produit en général à une
température d'environ 180 degrés quelle
que soit la taille et la forme du gard
ensuite ils ont identifié l'origine du
pop caractéristiques au moment de
l'explosion du grain de maïs quand la
vapeur s'échappe de la coque
une dépression se forment à l'intérieur
du crin c'est à ce moment précis que
retentit le pop un peu comme lorsqu'on
débouche une bouteille de champagne
c'est la dépression à l'intérieur de la
bouteille qui est à l'origine du bruit
enfin ils ont compris pourquoi le pop
corn sont au moment où la coque du grain
se fissure un morceau d'amidon en forme
de bras jaillit en se détendant comme un
ressort ce qui fait pour dire le pop
corn et voilà on obtient du maïs soufflé
pour terminer une petite pincée de sel
ou de sucre
de mon côté c'est plutôt sucre
et vous si vous avez aimé cette vidéo
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce bleus
merci les épis curieux pour les plus
gourmands en voici d'autres et pour ne
rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Musique]